[Music]
welcome to Jumanji no you're not
actually Jumanji I was a joke ok alright
don't laugh at the same time interrupt
through the recording anyway thank you
for coming I sort of triple thanks
really
thanks for either getting lunch quickly
and rushing over or missing lunch
potentially thanks again for there's a
key note it seems competing with us too
so appreciate you guys coming here and
then of course you guys gonna hang out
in movie theatres and super comfy seats
super quiet environment so hopefully we
can get through the slide 6 or 7 before
anyone takes it out alright there's no
popcorn today unfortunately and the
slides are not in IMAX
I tried but not an option um anyway
let's get jumping right in so my name is
Matt Tavis I'm a Solutions Architect and
what that means is I spend most of my
time working with partners customers
internal product teams trying to guide
people on how best to use the Google
cloud platform so what services to
consume best architectural approaches
the essay team focuses a lot on building
the solutions you see on the GCP website
so the solutions section has things that
are downloadable that's what we do so we
spend our time we try and learn things
from you and then we try and build out
templates and patterns that make sense
for everyone to consume later on sweet R
will jump up here one of our partners
from Nutanix
and he'll do a few slides as well we'll
do a quick handoff later on but I'll let
him introduce himself then but without
any further ado let's jump right in so
I'd love to start by talking about you
know our perspective on hybrid hybrids a
pretty heavily overloaded term in the
industry in general there's really no
single definition that were the captures
that it's pretty broad I mean you look
at the dictionary it's really the two
distinct things that are blended
together in some odd way that's hybrid
right that's so almost anything could
qualify as hybrid I'm gonna talk about
some of how we feel about it and how we
see Google platform contributing to its
further development but first it's
important to realize that hybrid is is a
reality it's not you know I've ran into
customers in the industry have been
working in the cloud for actually over
ten years so
always with Google with others as well
and you know it is a an industry term
that gets used a lot and often it's well
you know hybrid is not necessarily clean
it's not a pure but it's actually
reality that most people are dealing
with this survey you see here 87% of
enterprises are looking at a hybrid
strategy have some form of it
56% are already using multiple types of
deployments multiple clouds and only 40%
are really capturing you know cloud
first as a model and even the folks that
are doing cloud first often have to go
through some transition hybrid is a
transitory phase as well so you're gonna
probably run into this unless you've
never built any software
who here has no software to run
excellent ok good
you have no software to run you probably
have other talks you want to go to this
is about people that have software they
have to move it and and how do you do
that in a way that's that's efficient
and makes sense so with that hybrid is
persistent and it's pragmatic one of the
one of the ways to look at hybrid and I
like to misuse terms so I like to tap
and other scientific disciplines like
thermodynamics and entropy is a common
term around how things when left alone
eventually devolve into a more chaotic
state or maybe more natural chaos and
hybrid really in many ways is the
expression of that in the IT landscape
as your platform evolves as you add new
services new capabilities as you add
extensions to your architecture you
oftentimes end up in a blend of
technologies a blend of environments a
blend of services and so this is
something that naturally occurs but
that's not necessarily bad news hybrid
in fact is actually desired for many
reasons so enterprises in general often
never single source IT you know that's a
common common knowledge don't put your
legs in all your eggs in one basket so a
hybrid strategy is inherently if you're
gonna use multiple clouds multiple
environments the other thing is you get
some advanced advantages of extending
your environment with the best of breed
so hybrid is an opportunity to say hey
I've got the best pieces from this
platform and I want to blend them with
the best pieces from that platform and
that a functionally is hybrid so there's
some benefits to that approach as well
and then fundamentally embracing hybrid
which i think is you know what I'm
trying to encourage folks to do
influences how you think about IT and
how you wield it so instead of thinking
of every transition or every migration
as a I'm going from A to B and B is my
final state you recognize that hybrid
will continue to exist over time that
means you adopt approaches that are not
about n plus 1 but what's beyond that so
if you're going from A to B what's C
look like what are the tools and
techniques I'm gonna want to use going
forward even beyond this current
transition how do I think about
capturing and and choosing tools that
are gonna benefit me over time and not
just for this one period so thinking
about that approach differently changes
perhaps how you think about the partners
you select the tools you choose and the
approaches you take so all in mass
migrations people talk about and they're
fantastic it's a great idea but even
with that over time the technology
landscape will change you will end up
probably in some form of hybrid again
later after that mass migration so
thinking about how to tackle that in a
efficient long-term way is definitely a
beneficial to you and your migrations so
it comes in many forms as you can see
here we have on the bottom your lives
the bottom there you go we have kind of
like a open source e cloudy type tools
here my datacenter more traditional bits
some other cloud that's not GCP and of
course the Google platform so you know
hybrid could be I'm blending two data
centers with a disparate technologies
not as exciting for this talk but that's
a form of hybrid or I'm connecting my
traditional with a whole bunch of cloud
you know cloud first or cloud native
services alternatively I'm using a
common set of tools a common set of open
source tools across multiple
environments here you see kubernetes
down below gke up above tensorflow down
below machine learning engine up above
frightened so that's another blend of
hybrid technologies and of course I
would in my in my definition of hybrid
point to multi cloud as a hybrid mental
model because you're actually blending
different approaches and different
technologies across that so all of these
really are hybrid of a form and so there
may be things you'll run into and
they're all valid and reasonable
depending on what makes sense for you
and then I like and hybrid is is a
course at every layer thinking about
hybrid it's not a
a particular architecture inherently it
generally is a blend of things and so it
actually fits and there's tools that are
needed across the board at every layer
fundamental to the whole thing is
obviously networking right
there's no hybrid architecture that I've
ever seen that doesn't have a network in
it so kind of makes sense so you have to
have a series of tools and you have to
have a rich platform and technology that
allows you to extend your network as it
stands today
and integrate other services and then
build a dynamic network on the other end
to support your hybrid migration so you
know in GCP we have a variety of
different tools you know from dedicated
and partner interconnect for bridging
that gap as well as obviously VPNs and
then you know things like virtual
private cloud load balancing cloud VPN
is ways to build out that network on the
clock and that map's back to your
traditional you know routers and
switches that you might own today at the
next layer up you have infrastructure as
a service tech capabilities so
traditionally over here you've got your
old you know your VMs you've got your
persistent disk you might have this sort
of looks like a very traditional legacy
virtualized infrastructure in the
enterprise and a series of tools like
the transfer of climate compliance or
even our new fellow strata tools that
actually allow you to migrate VMs in
minutes so that's how you get those
existing kind of lift and shift models
to move those components over and on you
know on the on the GCP side you've got
compute engine and cloud storage even
cloud spanner to replace maybe some
traditional database technologies up top
the next layer of hybrid is thinking
about that application approach so in
the infrastructure layer you're maybe
blending you know some different types
of services or components at the
application layer you're saying look I'm
gonna pick a common tool chain a common
set of services like kubernetes across
the board is steel across the board and
I'm gonna run that in both environments
so I can actually have a single software
development stack everywhere and that
often is not everyone goes that way from
hybrid perspective because maybe they're
not in containers today but this is a
fundamental model that you know you see
with our cloud service platform
announcement you know we're espousing
this idea of a common tool chain
everywhere but it does require possibly
some rewrite so that but that is
something to consider
how do you get to that
and that's a modernization step
generally for existing applications and
then fundamentally on top what I think a
lot of folks forget about in the hybrid
model is this idea of a common set of
services API management you know
visibility in terms of monitoring across
the board as you add services and
capabilities in multiple environments
the management infrastructure gets even
more complicated so thinking about a way
to pick tools and technologies that give
you visibility across the board like for
example stackdriver which can work
across multiple clouds as well as even
your own platform or Apogee which can
work across multiple environments as
well so those are definitely key
elements to consider across the board
now our approach to hybrid is what I'd
like to talk about next but after a
drink of water I talked about the
network the network is the foundation
without the network you don't have a
strong hybrid story and ideally to make
a lot of these architectures work you
have to have a rich global performant
network and that's what Google's been
building for 18 plus years you know we
have 17 regions 125 points of presence
we have over a hundred thousand feet of
undersea cable that we've invested in
this is the largest private network in
the world and we continue to build that
out this is our continued ongoing
commitment this means that you have
access when you use GCP with your hybrid
environment to this entire network and
as your data flows between regions
between endpoints you have that that
backbone that we've built for our own
platform and you can actually ride on
top of that world-class infrastructure
and we like to make it easy for you to
get involved in that so we obviously
have you know the Google network but we
also build multiple ways to get in
there's premium versus standard and
different network approaches there's
also you can just do you know VPN
tunnels if you want something quick and
easy but we also have you know dedicated
interconnects or partner interconnects
where you can drop into a data center
that you're already in and drop a simple
you know 10 gig connection across the
data center to tap right into the Google
Network so giving you that flexibility
is key and that is the foundation of any
hybrid solution that you have a strong
scalable global network
the other thing that's important and
this is kind of more of a positioning
piece around how we think about hybrid
is that fundamentally hybrid if it's
going to be effective is it has to work
in a lot of different locations it has
to come to you and meet you where you're
at so our our principle here and you saw
this in the cloud services platform is
that you know we're gonna make it better
with open innovation so we're gonna
innovate is with the fastest out there
we're gonna build you know the latest
technologies we're gonna give you those
latest tools on the cloud but we're also
contributing those back into the open
source community so you can use that you
know the latest tensorflow
you know api's and capabilities on a
machine learning engine you know on
google cloud but also you can use it
in-house as well so that's the
fundamental focus that we take and why
we think hybrid with Google makes so
much sense is because we're gonna give
you a common set of tools and
technologies you don't have to have you
know developers that understand the
Google service that you know then have
to learn another service for your
in-house platform so you can actually
standardize across the board and this
makes it portable it makes it extensible
it makes it available everywhere you
need to run and then of course there's
innovation that we continue to
contribute is about not just delivering
value today but also going forward so as
we continue to evolve kubernetes we will
do that in gke but we'll also do that
you know in the kubernetes open source
projects as well so you're getting those
innovations across the board these are
some of the key things in the last say
six plus months we've done kind of
hybrid space I'm not gonna read all of
them this is being recorded and I'm
seeing photos being snapped so that's
awesome you know a lot of things we're
doing around the infrastructure layer or
this transfer appliance Avella strata
you know things like that cloud file
storage just came out partner
interconnects for tight integration with
your data center to give you high
throughput highly scalable network and
then of course you know five plus or
five regions we've added unto the
platform in the last six or seven months
right on the application layer you know
support for things like shared V PC a
memory store service for caching in the
platform you know pub/sub emulators for
various tools that are common like Kafka
private clusters to support your
architecture the way it fits from from a
application perspective and then in the
management space I think you saw a lot
in in the cloud services platform but
even before that we've already been
working strongly on integrating sto with
Apogee having a Pidgey expand to
multiple regions you have a way to
expose that API layer over your
applications around the globe and then
all the work and I am in terms of
conditions resource management so you
can not only deploy your infrastructure
where you need it but also manage it in
alignment with your own security
practices and principles that you have
inside your enterprise today and of
course the cloud services platform which
you've seen who's seen that makino
alright you're obviously all asleep
because there's on o hands somebody saw
it you saw it you saw right that's two
um four all right we're getting there
six so the idea here is we want to take
what we've done in the in the open
source projects like sto and kubernetes
and we want to make that available where
it's needed and which is not only in our
the the GCP platform but also in your
data center today and so you know the
cloud build function the cloud build and
serverless capabilities for people who
are builders don't want an integrated
workflow server lists you know as baked
on top of the gke platform
Jiki on Prem which gives you the ability
to run kubernetes both in the cloud and
on-premise a consistent way stack driver
and sto integration so you actually have
the ability to see API usage across the
your existing infrastructure internally
but also in the cloud and then fully
managed SEO is another key piece there
and of course this all integrating with
the apogee API management gives you a
single management plane across multiple
environments and so the way to look at
this is I actually drew an architecture
diagram why not and so you see here
there's a whole bunch of approaches to
the cloud and they're all kind of
represented now as part of this cloud
services platform architecture so here
you've got your your your legacy cloud
nope the things that never move that's
they're very exciting over there we'll
leave them alone but they can actually
be it still connected to the cloud with
a dedicated interconnect and then using
the Apogee API platform as a way to
expose legacy services with a web
service interface right a very common
approach to help people kind of expose
something that's maybe they want a way
to call into it but they don't want to
be able to have to rewrite it so put an
API layer over the front and then
staying on from in the enterprise data
center
you can use GK on Prem to modernize in
place right I want to improve my
application move to a modernized
architecture but I don't want to move it
out of the data center
maybe it's tightly coupled to other
services in the architecture I can leave
that there but I can add a managed it
steel mesh over the front over the top
of it so I can actually control API
access even though it's in my data
center and then of course that same
approach can be applied to my remote
site so for example I might be you know
a retail organization and I have you
know hundreds of stores well guess what
I got to still control the services
running in the gke or the Jiki on Prem
in those stores as well just like I
control the services in my enterprise
data center so you have that common
modeler and then here you know in the
cloud platform you might do you know
lift and shift where you bring some
things over with sort of El Estrada but
also the move and improve like I'm gonna
move some features over and then improve
how they run today tying that into the
the manages to you and what you get with
you know this particular approach from a
hybrid perspective is one you get
central cluster management now you can
control the you know kubernetes that's
running across all of your environments
not just the one that's in the cloud
right you have a centralized way in
which you can view how those clusters
are performing what they're doing and
upgrade across the across the board you
also have a build cloud build with a
common tool chain so as I build
containers as I build those artifacts I
want to deploy them I now have a common
set of services and api's that I can use
across the board and I can deploy that
to any of those clusters and then the
other thing is fundamental to a true
hybrid models of centralized API
management this ability to you know
capture a who can access what in my
architecture so if you go down the
microservices model the ability to say
you know front end here can call back in
there and control you know throughput
rates access to those various services
all through a centralized API management
layer now that's obviously a little
forward thinking that was our
announcement this morning that's kind of
where I see hybrid going it to some
degree and there's also a lot of other
tools in space and and we'll hear more
about that but what they're what we're
seeing in terms of real use cases today
I thought I'd cover that just so folks
can you know get excited about what
might apply to their particular business
today so there's a few
we see kite quite commonly I'm one isn't
this idea of invoking legacy
dependencies moving pieces of my
architecture into the cloud but calling
back into existing services that I can't
move today or don't want to you know
mainframes large-scale packaged
applications that have too many
dependencies to be picked up today
things that you know maybe run an
infrastructure that you know doesn't
it's not cloud ready right but I want to
still tap into that from the cloud
that's a pretty common you know
front-end calling into a back-end kind
of model in hybrid another is cross
environment execution so I want all the
benefits of CI CD I want a fantastic dev
test process I want flexibility for my
development teams I want to move quickly
but it turns out I still needed to play
that code in my oil rig right well you
know that's gonna be a model you're not
gonna change your oil rig necessarily
tomorrow so hey you know the ability to
use the cloud as a as a cross
environment you know kind of execution
development environment is a common
platform but deploying directly from
there it to the edge is common as well
and then edge computing in general I
want to add a whole bunch of sensors
capabilities to my architecture I want
to gather a whole bunch of new data that
I've never processed before I probably
don't have the processing power of the
storage that I need how can I use the
cloud as a way to extend my architecture
to capture all that information
aggregate it feed it back into my
existing application and then use that
as a sort of a blended hybrid model um
so some examples of that you see the GCP
front end right you know I got my
back-end services my my existing stuff I
then have all my client traffic coming
into you know global load balancers I
can hit whatever region is closest to my
customers I can capture all the
front-end work that I need to do on that
and then you know when I do I can use
interconnects back or a VPN back into my
existing architecture to tap into other
systems like say ERP or or back-end you
know inventory management things like
that
that's a pretty common scenario we see
quite a bit might apply to what you're
doing today the other one we see as I
mentioned IOT right you've got you know
sure my devices are gonna continue to
reach back into my existing my existing
you know on from infrastructure but then
at the same time I can use cloud pub/sub
IOT core data flow in this whole array
of analytics and storage services to
capture process and then aggregate that
data so then I can feed the results back
into my existing architecture for maybe
you know I'll put back to my my devices
so I have this ability to take this
maybe smaller scale footprint and then
add a whole bunch of managed services
and data processing capability as a
hybrid model building obviously a hybrid
network interconnect in between those
two some other examples we're seeing is
just tapping into the the global network
of gzp as a way to get footprint around
the globe right as you expand your
business as you expand where you your
customers are coming from you want this
availability everywhere you want to be
able to have the closest location we
tapped into so there's global
availability the 17 regions is a huge
benefit and you can go from tapping into
one region to get into that network we
saw earlier to get around the globe
another is jurisdictional or data
sovereignty you might be tapping into a
new market and there might be rules
about where the data has to live has to
be processed
having regions there available to you
right away very example but you still
want you know visibility coming back
into your central IT infrastructure so
blending those those data storage and
processing requirements with tying it
back into your existing centralized
approach and architecture and then the
last which is quite common is this idea
of extending an architecture with cloud
services you know I think IOT is one
example but I'll dive into another one
here which is actually let me go back
real fast another one here which is this
idea of like let's say I want to add ml
or I want to add Big Data right these
things are things I can tap into my
architecture and I don't have to rebuild
it I just have to figure out way to pump
that data across and bring the results
back into my platform so in terms of
regional availability you know here's it
you can imagine this kind of a model
model where you have a global load
balancer you know you're exposing two
customers across the globe and then
building proxies in the region's running
individual sort of localized services
for various performance needs but then
fundamentally tapping that back into a
and to interconnect in terms of feeding
that data back into you know your your
maybe you centralized or lower lessened
footprint enterprise platform the other
one being the Big Data example when we
talked about you know yeah I've got a
ton of applications out over here don't
fit on the screen I didn't
the screams would be big enough so I was
wrong about the Hat obviously so his
hell you know zaps over here and then
that data is being pumped Pumped through
over a variety of different capabilities
whether it be a transfer appliance you
know transfer service or just a VPN
interconnect you know whatever makes
sense into you know an event stream ETL
streaming staging buckets very streaming
and storage services they give you your
time series analysis your data warehouse
on bigquery and then you can build a
whole analytics and reporting dashboard
over the top of that which can be
exposed either in the cloud or you can
even pump some of that data back for
reporting on front so another common
classic hybrid model we're seeing in the
market today um so this is the just
summary slide that shows them again
there you go
but fundamentally we're obviously doing
a lot for the cloud services platform
and we've been doing a lot in terms of
commitment to open source tools and
technologies but we also let the
platform to be open for our partners as
well this you know hybrid fundamentally
means a blending of disparate
technologies and we recognize that many
of you are working with existing
partners today you have a wide array of
services or capabilities that you're
trying to bridge into the cloud platform
and so we think that it's as fundamental
that we actually make this platform
extensible and allow others to
participate as well so you can your best
choice tools are available for you as
well so whether it be you know multi
cloud management capabilities that's why
we expose all of our you know api's so
you can actually tap into that from a
variety of tools and management consoles
hybrid applications when you want to run
containers everywhere gke allows you do
that you can run you know kubernetes on
Prem you can run it with with other
hosting partners as well hybrid services
across the board in terms of securing
and monitoring services across clouds
and then you know hybrid infrastructure
so that commitment to the VMS that can
move around you know V to V V to C you
know that cloud interconnect and data
migration their fundamentals and
obviously we have a whole bunch of
partners in the space but what I'd love
to do is turn it over to one of our
partners right now to talk more about
his story
and their solutions sri jiva pali who's
a general manager of cloud services in
botanics thanks for joining us Matt hey
folks my name is Sheila they were a Poli
yeah that's you and my responsibility is
to drive forward hybrid cloud strategy
at Nutanix
and I'll talk about what that means in
upcoming slides and that's given you a
ton of information on you know his
perspective on hybrid and the customer
problems they see I would like to do the
same from the mechanic standpoint before
I go any further I'd like to see a show
fans as to how many of you actually
heard of Nutanix yeah I see okay that's
quite a few it's quite a few so let's
start there just just to recap what what
what botanics does as a company in what
what's a mission statement right we
deliver infrastructure data center
infrastructure for customers on-premises
environment and our mission is really to
bring cloud like simplicity and agility
and cost economics to on-premises data
center environments and we build turn
key infrastructure stack that allows
customers to focus on their applications
instead of low level infrastructure
Const constructs we're about nine years
old and we've got 10,000 customers so
far it's a fast growing company so how
do we how do we accomplish our mission
what do we what do we do to realize our
goals well to begin with we took a deep
look at data center technology choices
built and delivered piecemeal to
customers and the operational silos that
they create traditional architectures
require to plan and procure compute
storage networking virtualization all of
these independently and manage the
lifecycle of each of these components
independently that results in long lead
times dedicated teams specialized skills
and in general a pretty big operational
hazard right so what have we done we
went ahead and designed a new system
that coalesced all those technologies
that you see on the Left compute storage
networking virtualization management
automation orchestration and built a
integrated single turnkey appliance form
factor and the result of that is its
unparalleled simplicity as far as
operations
Center operations was concerned and
planning is concerned and the value for
customers is evident from the rate at
which that the company has been growing
with time right having said that now
what are we doing with with Google and
GCP what's our joint vision I can get to
that as well yeah there you go
our goal is to deliver a seamless
one-click hybrid cloud experience in
platform for customers who right-size
their applications and workloads between
private and public clouds what exactly
do we mean by that essentially as you
start from your on-premises data center
environments and you try to figure out
an access path to the public cloud to
realize very specific hybrid use cases
and we'll talk about more about what
those use cases are we want to give you
the best seamless experience possible
without having to go through the
complexities in transformations in
redesigning in refactoring applications
so that that's the that's the access
path that we've conceived and we'll talk
more about how exactly are we going
about realizing this vision there are a
set of capabilities that we're offering
to make this hybrid journey seamless for
our customers and I'll break it down
into these three sort of broad areas one
is you know you got to start with
transforming your own data center
because that's where most of your
applications are running today and what
have you done to sort of bring a degree
of simplicity and agility to that
environment and that's where Nutanix as
a company is bringing value to our
customers it were proven to provide
agility and simplicity and transform
your existing data center to be more
cloud like that's that's been our
mission all along in the success path
for us anyway now in addition to
transforming data centers we're also
allowing customers to transform their
applications redesigning them to be more
micro services like using technologies
like kubernetes delivered natively on
premises off of our appliances that's
again you know that's think of that as
Google services delivered natively out
of Nutanix platforms and our goal
eventually is that you consume a
combination of Nutanix and Google
services in respect to of the location
they could be on-premises off premises
but in the end you can you can start
building your applications in a way that
you know you progressively modernize
them without having to worry about
location and transformation
another key aspect which is related to
what I just said is the ability to move
applications back and forth between on
premises in the cloud without having to
read again redesign or retransform them
the there's an offering that's new that
we call high cloud services and I'll
talk more about what that means
Nutanix stack for GCP you can use I for
DCP integrated with our on-premises
offering allows you to move workloads
back and forth as your business requires
without having to go through many of the
you know typical complexities that one
goes through for cloud migration right
and related to that is essentially
orchestration and automation of
placement of these workloads and I'll
talk more about how another product of
mechanics which is calm plays a big part
of in solving that problem and finally
eventually you you want to get to a
place where you refactor the application
to optimally run in the cloud therefore
you're taking advantage of all the
native cloud services and not just doing
a lift and shift from on-premises to the
cloud and we help you progressively
refactor those applications through a
through a series of tightly integrated
services between Google and Nutanix so
those are at a high level those are the
capabilities that that that we're not me
designing together now what use cases do
they enable you to solve again as I said
any use case that starts with your
on-premises environment and needs to
access the cloud as a seamless extension
of your on-premises environment would
benefit from these from these joint
offerings the first and foremost
disaster recovery and business
continuity this has been a problem
that's been it that's that's pretty hard
to address traditionally because it's
complex in nature and what we've done is
we've built a dr to the cloud solution
that's tightly integrated with our
on-premises offering and with with
Google and e-tanks together you can
leverage the GCP cloud as the target for
your as a dr target for in in the case
of a failure right a related use case to
dr is lift and shift as as we talk to
many customers they're looking to
miniaturize the data send a footprint
and and trying to figure out a way to
move workloads into the cloud while we
can
some existing workloads on-premises how
do we make that motion seamless in the
lab you to still have backward
connectivity and access ability to
what's running on Prem so that in the
end you realize that true hybrid
situation where your your actual
workloads are spanning both the public
and private clouds without you having to
go through again a series of investments
in data center migration technologies
and so forth right and another use case
is cloud bursting and there's and we'll
talk about a specific example where
there's a customer who actually wanted
additional capacity in the cloud based
on fluctuating demand from their users
and how do we enable that use case but
allowing you to expand into the cloud
just as much as your applications need
as though that's that's sort of a
seamless extension of your of your
existing platforms so these are some of
the use cases and the broad theme is
that any use case that is gravitated in
your on-premises environment but needs
either intermittent or event-driven
access to public cloud services will
will benefit from these joint offerings
all right sorry about that there was a
little bit of a technical glitch so I
spoke about the why and the what then
what what why are we embarking on this
partnership and what use cases can be
addressed let's talk a little bit about
the how what product offerings
specifically will help us address the
use cases that I just spoke about the
centerpiece of it all is actually to
enable a seamless hybrid experience the
first thing to solve for is to keep the
same operational paradigm the same
interfaces the same tooling the same
workflows to manage your applications
independent of location and there's a
product offering from Nutanix called
comm which stands for cloud application
lifecycle management and it allows you
to manage the lifecycle of your
applications across multiple clouds and
by lifecycle I mean application
deployment upgrades expansion visibility
security all those elements that you
would take care of as you design and run
your applications Khan gives you a
consistent interface to perform all
those operations across different clouds
and the way you would do that is you
would create a comm blueprint think of
that as you know a set of instructions
that describes the constitution of your
application and its infrastructure
requirements and dependencies and once
you've designed and built the blueprint
you can repeatedly deploy it across
different clouds while maintaining the
same operational consistency in the way
you manage your applications it could be
you know the target cloud could be
private cloud on Nutanix
or public cloud like DCP and we come
allows you to manage not just VM based
applications but also containerized
workloads as well comm blueprints also
allows you to provision and manage
kubernetes with to a control plane
through a through one-click experience
now that's a little bit about you know
homogenizing consumption into
operational interfaces and that's what
comm enables you to do but a true hybrid
stack goes beyond just consumption and
where the need is to ensure that all
aspects of your workload stay consistent
on both sides including things like
performance scale availability security
data protection things of that nature
this calls for a different level of
building hybrid and by that I mean it's
the same platform that needs to extend
between your on-premises environment and
the target public cloud and that's where
our next offering which we call zai
cloud services accomplishes that's
exactly what it does think of it as a
native extension of of our net of our in
a price cloud platform into the public
cloud into various public clouds
including GCP and it's our technology
stack it's the same software technology
stack that Nutanix has built that we
deliver on-premises now it's delivered
as a service in or in various public
clouds including data centers that we
run in to operate but also within the
GCP regions with Zhai not only do you
maintain operational consistency as you
expand into public cloud but you retain
all the applications SLA s and the
security model and performance
characteristics and everything else that
you would have carefully designed as you
built and run your application right
it's because and you could do that only
because it's the same platform on both
sides and the first service that we are
offering with Zhai is disaster recovery
as a service and we plan to expand the
set of use cases to encompass other
hybrid scenarios as well and
specifically with Google we are offering
Zhai services within a DCP region
co-located with low latency access to
the rest of the GCP services so if
you're a customer who is looking to
transition to the public cloud for
either your existing workloads or to
build new workloads you can leverage a
combination of mechanic services and GCP
services through this joint offering now
in addition to proximity there's a few
more things we're doing on the on the
interface consumption side to make the
whole experience seamless for our joint
customers I'll talk through some of
those yeah as I get the right slide a
lot of this is related platform
integrations to enable and ensure a
seamless experience so firstly it's
going to be an integrated portal there's
a common portal from which customers can
consume a
a combination of mechanic services and a
select set of GCP services that we will
make accessible through this portal and
those select set would be the set of
services that would make sense to
consume from within Sai things like big
data bigquery that can actually act on
data that's the your data that's
residing in within the Sai cloud
services anyway another common problem
that customers experiences management of
credentials and through a single sign-on
experience we allow you to maintain a
common identity to access a combination
of against I and Nutanix services so
that you don't really have to manage a
different set of credentials for each of
your employees or operators who are
managing and administering these these
resources we consolidate bills and you
get a single bill from loot annex that
constant that captures both charges
related to DCP and charges related to
the new tan excise services so you're
not dealing with two payment systems and
to two ways of tracking tracking your
bills and things of that nature and
finally this is important and map
touched upon this before also which is
network connectivity and establishing
network connectivity is really usually
very cumbersome and painful we unify
that in the sense that you could use a
single network connection to access a
combination of both sigh services and
DCP services and that connection could
be a VPN connection over the Internet or
it could be a you know DCP interconnect
as a way to reach a combination of you
know DCP services in Sai services and if
you see all of these sort of
capabilities together the goal is to
enable a more seamless simplified
experience to access what we call a set
of hybrid services so I spoke a lot
about you know essentially various
capabilities and mission statements and
use cases and so forth let's bring all
of it together using a actual customer
example here's a here's a real scenario
where a where there's an existing joint
customer of mechanics and ng CP and they
were interested in essentially procuring
exists compute capacity on the
on demand as in when their application
needs
so during peak seasons it's an
application that serves both internal
and external users for that for that
organization and during peak season they
need capacity for that application to
expand on demand it's a pretty standard
web application that that consists of
Apache web servers and Oracle databases
and JBoss application servers and
primarily they wanted the web server
capacity to expand on demand without
human intervention and without any kind
of lead times and without over procuring
capacity now it's a pretty standard
cloudbursting use case and I'm sure many
of you've heard of this use case before
but it's pretty hard to accomplish
without the right degree of automation
and without having to read transform or
change the nature in which the your
applications run especially if you are
looking to access the public cloud as a
way to procure that additional capacity
so we've implemented or in the process
of implementing a solution for this
customer that includes a lot of the
components that we spoke about at the
com acts as the overarching
orchestration layer and it's constantly
monitoring performance util and
utilization of the application and it's
it's built to orchestrate new web VMs in
DCP and this is actually either within
Zhai in DCP and therefore if you need
more capacity on the web without any
kind of operator intervention the system
itself detects that okay it's reached a
threshold at which point it needs to
spin up these instances and it launches
them it adds them to the web farm it
does other forms of automation things
like assigning IP addresses building
connectivity back to the on-premises
environment with the actual database
runs and modifying DNS records and
things of that nature all the automation
tasks that you would otherwise manually
do right and we have we leverage as I
was saying that common network
connectivity between GCP resources and
Zhai resources as a way to establish
connectivity between on-premises and the
cloud environment and there you have it
essentially this is how we've solved
this customers use case and if you see
it's
the fact that zai is running inside GCP
that this this automation has become a
minimal in the sense that the customer's
workloads need not have been transformed
in any way
there has been no redesign of their
applications the way they've constructed
their virtual machines and the way
they've designed and characterized
performance for their applications on
their on premises platform all of those
characteristics are retained as these
instances burst into the into the public
cloud it's a pretty simple example but
it illustrates essentially the power of
the giant solution because it addresses
things like automation and the and
seamless expansion without the need for
refactoring your applications right and
the benefits to customers is really the
simplicity that brings to the table and
the economic advantage of adding
capacity only when you need it right
guaranteed availability and these are
you know this is a pretty business
critical application and therefore
guaranteeing availability and
performance SSL is for this application
while you're taking advantage of the
economic elasticity is critical right
and it also illustrates the way in which
workloads can be moved I showed you a
cloud bursting use case you can clearly
see how this can be extended over to a
mobility use case where instead of
bursting into the cloud you could
actually move that entire application
over into the cloud using exactly the
same constructs and the same tools that
we built to address this use case anyway
so hopefully that gives you a sense for
the why and the what and the how along
with the actual real example that
illustrates sort of what we're bringing
together between Nutanix and Google so I
will be around in the night annex booth
in the conference so if you have any
additional questions and myself and my
colleagues would be happy to answer them
thank you for your time and have a great
afternoon Thanks
appreciate I don't think we have any
more slides but you know I think the the
point that we're trying to make here if
I can wrap it up is really the our our
goal at Google is really to provide you
a hybrid solution that meets you where
you're at like depending on what you
need for today's approach it fits your
business needs it can you know as you've
seen it can move existing applications
you can modernize and improve you can
networks you can provide all the tools
and capabilities to meet you where at
and and help you meet your business
goals and what is the most efficient
fashion for your business going forward
as you go into your cloud transition
with that we actually have a twist
ending to this movie which is that we
actually a time for questions I didn't
think we're gonna be able to have that
but you know it turns out either I talk
too fast or I missed the slide so there
are microphones on that side and this
side or if you want to scream it at me
because you're in the middle and I can
repeat it that's an option too
but we have five little over five
minutes if you have no questions and
want to run away I get it
thank you very much for your time and we
look forward to seeing you at the
conference oh and don't forget if you
are running away tomorrow and the only
reason I'm plugging this is because I'm
proctoring cloud hero it's an
interactive devops game if you want to
like literally build an app real time
for a challenge to see who gets the
highest score there are prizes and there
are capes actually oddly enough you
should look for us
you
[Music]